as soon as you have somebody who you
want to bring in for sales what we're
testing for is the speed of response
because you can test work ethic by how
quickly they get back to you because you
are a lead to them number two is that
what we want is somebody who's
intelligent so if somebody sounds like
an idiot then it's the impression that
they're going to be giving of your brand
which is probably not a good thing the
next one is you want somebody who can
listen so if someone's dominating the
conversation they're talking they're you
know motor mouthing it's not a good idea
you want somebody who's kind of an
ambivert who somebody you can listen and
can talk when it's time and socially
aware finally you want someone who's
coachable you can measure coachability
by saying Hey I want you to role play
with me in this situation and you just
give them a little bit of context you'd
be like and to be clear I don't care
about how well you sell me I just want
to hear you talk through things what
you'll do is you'll give them feedback
and then ask them to try again now if
someone can take the feedback without an
ego then you have somebody who's
coachable and if they make Improvement
on the second try then you know that
they can improve if you have those
things beyond the obvious one of them
being hungry and wanting to do it and
hopefully having sales experience in the
past then you have the requisites for
somebody who could be a good salesman
for your organization